Etymology,
semantics and meaning change.
So far. We followed the trail of various
forms of a word as it changed over time,
but just stating that for example,
Quain became queen ignores one crucial
aspect and aspect that initially attracts
most amateur enthusiasts of etymology.
Semantics.
When it comes to Etymology,
semantics deals with the meaning
of words and parts of words. Now,
semantics tends to be fuzzy in two ways.
First,
the relationship between the meaning of
a word and its form is generally opaque.
Second,
the semantic relationship between word
forms given that they're meaning is known
and even between word roots and words
derived from those same routes through
word formation is
approximate and variable. Uh,
consider the relationship between the
meaning of house and the meaning of home
or the etymological re in
remain versus in reappear,
we cannot simply set semantic
relatedness to true or false.
We have to be aware of and
capture the gradations of meaning.
Like sound informed,
meaning changes over time.
We can classify meaning changes into
types abstract too, or from concrete,
general two or from specific
temporal two or from Lockette IV.
We can also consider the origin of
a meaning change or the influence of
languages. For example, calcs, calcs form.
When speakers borrow patterns found in
another language to express a meaning
rather than bar.
The Latin expressed the expression,
we are locked here for our
galaxy English speakers CALC.
We are lack there as a new native
term Milky Way. Other times,
semantic loans occur when a language uses
preexist preexisting word or phrase to
cover a borrowed meaning.
We can also talk about
meeting and use words in use.
Maybe this be described as
literary poetic, archaic,
obsolete, obsolescent
jargon, colloquial, slang,
preferred and so on.
But however we classify it,
semantic changes not as systematic as
sound change under the real regularity
hypothesis. We expect
that it, for example,
if the African became the in a language
words that once began with that,
we'll now start with Z.
Don't expect the same from say an
abstract to concrete semantic change.
Not all abstract meanings will
become concrete in a language.
A last note about meaning change.
Uh,
the basic core vocabulary of a language
contains words that tend not to be
replaced and whose meanings do not
shift as much as the name implies.
These words include basic terms like
family members, terms for for earth,
Sun and other words learned
early and often. Um,
let's go back and look at
our etymology of Queen.
You saw that the word came
from old English Quinn.
Let's add our semantics in old English.
That word meant woman.
What's more the Proto Germanic word,
Quinn is and most cognates and other
Indo European languages like Greek Kunae
mean woman or wife.
It's safe to say that the pro Indo
European root Gwane also meant woman.
This is an example of meaning change.
The meaning shifts from general woman
to a more specific female monarch.
As you read etymologies
or build an etymology,
there are some conventions worth noting.
The source language,
word and meaning are indicated
for earlier attested forms.
Parts of speech are sometimes given,
such as now an adjective or verb language.
Names are abbreviated and dates and
sources support more thorough etymologies.
The complex relationships between cognates
and dialects are board boiled down to
clear examples with relevant semantic
information given. For each example,
either by choosing the most representative
attested word or by citing a
reconstructed ancestral form.
Comparative examples are also cited.
Again,
reconstructions are marked
with an asterisk and um,
words of trace back as far as possible.
Sometimes in etymology
becomes unclear contested,
in which case the uncertainty is mentioned
and the multiple possible origins are
cited. For instance, there a double
etymologies and cases of influence.
Um, the English. Now fuse
comes from Italian Fuso,
but it's a dermatology was
influenced by the French word fuzzy.
Let's conclude this discussion
of Etymology by considering
the context in which
we may stumble upon etymologies,
you'll often find it,
I'm ologies and major dictionaries
following definitions of many words.
You can also get your
hands on dictionaries of
Prodo language, root words.
If you're interested in doing etymology
and reverse determining the words that
have descended from some root word in
a specific reconstructed language like
Prodo, Indo European or Prodo, Mayan.
A common source of
etymologies is folk etymology,
the popular telling and retelling
of the stories behind the word folk.
Etymologies often focus on
names and popular phrases
like mind your p's and q's.
Of course, full get them ologies that
are not always factually correct,
but more importantly,
they're never accurate enough to count
as thorough linguistic etymologies.
Folk etymologists are
interested in storytelling,
entertainment, and credibility,
not precision and evidential
support. Speaking of names, uh,
on a mastic studies,
the etymology of proper names,
automatics is different because the
meaning of words that turn into names, uh,
10 to become vestigial.
The name proper comes to refer to
the identity of a person or place,
but the etymology still
interests even non specialists.
What's more words derived from the same
source can change in different ways when
they're used as a proper noun.
Names may be more conservative over
time or capture the history of and
interactions with surrounding languages.
For example,
the French name Jack preserves an old
nominative singular case ending s which
common nouns lost in French.
The Spanish name [inaudible] contains
a visit gothic route with a patronymics
suffix. That's all for this
introduction to etymology.
I hope it's helped you understand it.
Analogy. From a linguistic perspective,
you can see that, well, an etymology won't
tell you what the word actually means.
That's determined by how speakers
of a language use that word.
It does tell the sometimes fascinating
and unexpected history of the development
of words in a language. The next
time you hear look up an entomology,
you'll be able to take a more critical
and rigorous look at the origin of a word.